[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON ROBINSON: Providing our
users with a more interactive
movie discovery experience
is very important
to us here at Flixster.
Interactive posts allow users
to invite their friends to a
movie while they're looking
up a showtime.
Interactive posts are unique
because they feature a
prominent call to action back
to Flixster directly in a
Google+ stream.
SAMEER IYENGAR: We use
interactive posts to help
people share and purchase
products.
For example, when you write a
review, you have the option to
share it to your
Google+ stream.
If you've given it a good
rating, we use a special Add
to Cart call to action to allow
your friends to purchase
it directly from the stream.
JOCELYN MANGAN: People love to
talk about food, so we're
using interactive posts to allow
people to share the fact
that they made a reservation
or that they just found a
great-looking menu.
Our engineers were genuinely
excited throughout the
process, and the support that we
got from Google was great.
And we're excited to lay the
foundation for even cooler
features to come.